[Musique]
quand il rêvait
voyez faire sens a quitté les peaux qui
se formaient
partiront toutes ces cases on lui ce
qu'ils voulaient c'était pas des grandes
places mais des plages paradisiaques
il se voyait déjà dans une petite
cadillac pour traduire silice tête
jusqu'au costa rica mais c'était dans
céret
c'est le réveil il ne veut plus qu'on ne
veut pas les écouter dirige tous nous
disent fait ça fait si tu es toi faut
pas faire comme ça fait qui colle à la
peau la fais ton sac on y va tikhonov
quoi nous arrêtera oh là là paul fait-on
sacconi va chico est pour toi viens nous
arrêtera le temps est là si tu restes à
chaque seconde quand tu voudrais faire
le tour du monde
les tapas shon de tapas choix mais
qu'est ce que tu attends ça demain à la
villa kenya compte de solides racines
musicales masse des deux épaisseurs tu
peux arrêter de croire que tu n'y
arriveras pas je sais que tu en es
capable
mon projet fois pas plus lâche on est
tous dans le même cas et si tu ne me
feras pas regarde autour de toi t'es pas
ça se voit laissez nous rire on ne veut
plus faire bouffer on ne veut plus les
tout le monde nous dit ce fait ça fait
syrie et tétouan font pas faire comme ça
si cola la ola
fais ton sac on y va tikhonov quoi cas
nous arrêterons là la ola fais ton sac
on y va chico est pour toi viens nous
arrêtera le temps est long si tu restes
à chaque seconde
tu voudrais faire le tour du monde les
tapas choix non mais t'as pas choix non
mais qu'est ce que tu attends happy
nappy ce que trame nouvelle sonne comme
on l'a d'état qui taquinent au isnard
illusion vie privée de ben ali ben ali
zato la zone c locale six coaches
améliorations au fait on s'active à
chiconi temps ça nous aurait fait pour
ça qu on y va si l'on écoute nous
arrêtera le temps et
si tu restes à chaque seconde
tu pourrais faire le tour du monde mais
tapage pour un non mais t'as pas
choinière mais qu'est ce que tu attends
holla holla holla holla holla holla
holla holla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]